-I want to talk about
your movie.
But it's very exciting.
You're also working on
the reboot of "Roseanne."
-Roseanne. Roseanne.
-You're an executive producer.
-Didn't we watch "Roseanne"
growing up?
Yeah, cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And you -- Here is a photo of
you on set,
which is very exciting.
-That's on the couch.
What has it been like?
-It's been a nightmare.
-Uh-huh.
-You've worked with your heroes.
Or you have to talk to
your heroes all the time.
-Yes. And at "SNL,"
certainly that was --
-You're talking to me right now.
This must be hard for you.
-And I'm just barely,
barely keeping it together.
Obviously,
you're a hero of mine.
That's why we gave you
this paper cup.
-[ Laughing ] That's right.
I get a lot of respect
around here.
[ Laughter ]
You know, for me, I was so
excited to work on "Roseanne."
And I just -- I didn't foresee
how nervous I'd get around
John Goodman.
-Yeah.
-I'm such a big fan of
John Goodman.
-He's the sweetest person
on Earth.
-The nicest, the most talented.
And it's weird because growing
up, he was kind of like my dad,
but now, I kind of have a crush
on him.
It's weird.
I have bad thoughts.
And I do this thing, I guess,
when I get nervous around
a celebrity
that I'm starstruck by.
I just start lying.
[ Laughter ]
I try to just
ignore him entirely
because I know
I'll embarrass myself.
But he asked me
how my weekend was,
which should have been
a really quick exchange.
[ Laughter ]
And I had been on a book tour
at the time.
So I was like,
"I was on a book tour."
He's like, "Where did you go?"
I was like, "Oh, I went to
Florida, New York, St. Louis."
And he was like,
"Well, I'm from St. Louis."
And in that moment, I realized
I had not been to St. Louis.
[ Laughter ]
I was going to St. Louis.
But I couldn't say,
"Actually, I just lied to you."
Like that was -- So I just had
to like lean in.
And he's like,
"Where did you perform?"
And I was, like,
"The Panthenon."
[ Laughter ]
Because that kind of sounds like
a theater.
-Sure, yes.
-Like the Paramount.
-I would believe
there's a Panthenon. Yeah.
-Right. And he's like,
"When did that get built?"
And I'm like, "You don't know
about the Panthenon?"
I mean, I'm, like,
making him feel bad
for not knowing about St. Louis.
And then, he's like,
"Where did you stay?"
And I was like,
"The Doubletree."
[ Laughter ]
And he's like, "There's
a Doubletree in St. Louis?"
And I'm like, "The one city
there's not a Doubletree
is the one I lied."
And now, the window
has closed for this.
And if he watches this show,
I am fired.
[ Laughter ]
But, so, somewhere, John Goodman
is trying to book a hotel
at a Doubletree
that doesn't exist.
-And he can't believe he can't
get a show at the Panthenon.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, totally.
And like, I just -- I'm not good
with meeting my heroes.
I, just, I can't do it.
One time, John Cleese -- I did
something with John Cleese.
-That's one for me as well. Yup.
-I don't know. Monty Python.
And he came into my dressing
room, and we're talking.
And I was just, like,
trying to seem cool.
And I was like,
"I'm just going to, like,
have a drink of whatever
I'm drinking."
It was a lit candle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Literally, it gets to here
and I'm, like, "Oh, my God!"
[ Laughter ]
You know, so I just --
I don't think I'm designed to be
around my heroes.
-I want to talk about
"The Female Brain."
-By the way, I didn't bring
this out here for that prop.
It just worked out that way.
-Look, you know what?
-I am not a prop comic.
[ Laughter ]
I just want you to know
I'm getting a migraine.
So I brought this out
because I need it.
Just to be clear.
-Oh, well,
we all love the prop bit.
And now you ruined it.
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-"Guys, I know you loved
how I have the prop.
I have a terrible migraine."
-And so, my umbrella.
That was fortuitous.
-So, this is based on a book
by on the same name,
"The Female Brain."
How did you find -- How did you
come across the book?
-Do you ever shop online and the
store you're shopping at, like,
judges you with the purchases
they suggest?
-Yeah. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-My Amazon, the things they
suggest to me are so insulting.
Like, I'll be like,
"I need to buy a rubber band."
And it's like, "Did you mean
'Chicken Soup for the Soul?'"
I'm like, "No!"
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm just, like, buying
because I guess
I do buy a lot of
self-help books.
Not that I need it.
And they kept suggesting --
users who bought this item also
bought "The Female Brain."
And I'm like,
"I should just buy this
because they're going to keep
harassing me about it."
So I finally just bought it.
And then I read it, and it was
so empowering and interesting,
and I was like,
"I just really --
I think we should
make a movie of this."
I asked our friend Neil Brennan
if he would write with me.
-Neil Brennan, another very
funny comedian.
You guys have known each other
for years.
-Created "The Chappelle Show"
with Dave Chappelle.
No big deal. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How was --
How was collaborating?
Obviously, this is a film about
how the brains are different.
You guys have
very different brains.
How was that?
-Yeah, when you write with
someone,
like, especially of
the opposite sex,
it's like all the negative parts
of a relationship
and none of the positive parts.
It was only like -- it was just
fighting and driving
and no sex or vacationing.
[ Laughter ]
So we basically just tried to
make it as real as possible.
And we put ourselves in
situations
where we could actually
just fight it --
the actual scene out
and transcribe it.
So we basically just, like,
got paid to fight all day.
-That's not bad.
-It's like my dream job.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so we just
knocked it out.
And you know Neil.
He's the funniest.
-Great cast.
Sofia Vergara, Cecily Strong,
James Marsden, Blake Griffin.
Blake Griffin is so funny.
It's unfair.
-Comedy marvel?
-Comedy genius.
-Legend in the making?
-Yeah.
Blake Griffin, NBA superstar,
is way too funny.
-It's actually embarrassing.
-Yeah.
-To people whose first job
is to do comedy.
Like, we're all just like,
"Oh, my God. This is bad."
This is, like, his hobby.
He's better at this.
So, he is such a natural.
And, like, he improvised
a lot of it.
I can't even take credit
for a lot of it.
Neil knew him and, you know,
suggested it and made it happen.
-That's great.
-I think
you'll be very delighted.
-You are going to make
Blake Griffin
a different kind of star.
-Yeah.
Like, he needed some cash.
[ Laughter ]
But it's obviously --
He was also so tall.
Thank, God.
Cecily, we had to put her in
these huge heels
just so they could fit
in the same frame
because Blake is so tall,
it's hard to shoot him.
You just see, like, Blake
and, like clouds, you know?
[ Laughter ]
We had to get all these special
things to shoot him.
It was pretty funny.
-Well, well done.
And always so great to see you,
Whitney. Congrats on the movie.